the film director Olivia Wilde has a new
movie out which she says it's based on
you this insane man this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the in-cell
community in cell being these weirdo
loner men uh who are despicable in many
ways is that you are you the
intellectual hero to these people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice
is making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are and certainly
many young men are in that category and
you get these casual
insults these these in cells is what
does it mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them when she said that Olivia Wilde
it stung you didn't it oh by that time
you know
that as far as as critic critiques go
that was kind of low level I mean once I
got painted as
Red Skull you know magical super Nazi
that was kind of the end of the insults
there's no place past that so when
Olivia Wilde made those comments the
first thing I did was go look at the
preview for a movie which I quite liked
I thought I would go see that movie
probably and perhaps I will it didn't
really bother me my my family and I
talked about it right away and we were
able to respond to it with some degree
of humor which then people completely
misunderstood I said I hope that you
know that if I had to be played by
someone
he's a very good looking man and so if
that seems all right you know and then I
said something like I hope he gets my my
uh fashion style choice right when he
plays me and it was a joke all that was
a joke
you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
constantly
how many people
are dying for lack of an encouraging
word
[Music]
and how easy it is to provide that if
you're careful
you know give credit where credit is due
and to say
you're in that Force for good if you
want to be
do you believe you're not falsely good
net yes
in all the details probably not
you know no one's perfect
so
people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign